hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem in code and
decode strings so you can tell the
interface is a little bit different this
time and that's because we are going to
be solving this problem on lint code
because this is a premium leak code
problem and we can solve it for free on
the website lint code and also this is a
problem from the blind 75 list a list of
75 common leak code questions that we've
been tracking on this spreadsheet the
link to this will be in the description
if you want to take a look and we're
pretty much done with the main problems
i'm going to be solving another one
today a premium one in code and decode
strings this is a pretty decent problem
to understand so let's get into it so
it's a bit of a design algorithm because
we're going to have two different
functions that we want to implement so
we're given a list of strings and we
want to write two functions we want to
encode this list of strings into a
single string and you can kind of see
that down here we were given an input
list of strings lint code love you and
we want it to be a single string such as
this one in the bottom right and then
the d code is just going to be the
opposite of in code we're going to be
given a single string and we want to be
able to convert this string in into back
into that original list of strings that
we were given and it's up to us on how
we want to design this algorithm but the
tricky part is going to be that where
the basic assumption is that in our
input we could have any possible
character in the inputs not just limited
to lowercase a to z so the difficult
thing is going to be how do we create
some kind of delimiter between each word
how do we know when one word ends and
another word begins that's kind of what
we're going to be focusing on so let's
get into that solution so suppose we
were given two strings like this neat
and code and we want to convert it into
another string basically into a single
string right so a naive way would be
something like this right just say okay
neat code now the problem is okay we did
that the encode was fine but now we want
to decode this back into the two
original strings that we had but there's
no way for us to determine right because
we can't remember where one word ends
and another word begins right so we need
to have some kind of uh character or
something to separate words what if we
used a pound sign or something right
something like this or any character
maybe a question mark or something right
but this is like our special character
that's what's going to separate words
for us so in this case it works out
right we'll go character by character in
the input once we get to a pound sign
okay we'll say that this word ends so
we'll say okay we have
the first word neat and this is not
included in any of the words so we skip
it and then we get to the remaining
portion code and there aren't any more
pound signs so that works out in this
case right but basically our assumption
when we're using this pound sign is that
the pound is never going to actually
show up in any words what happens if we
have a word suppose in our word code in
the middle of the word we have a pound
sign right there's no reason why we
can't have something like this so in
that case when we when we take this and
encode it we're gonna get something like
this as the encoded string right and
then when we split it we're gonna have
three different words neat co and d e
but in the original you can see we only
had two words but when we get our output
we're gonna end up splitting this into
three words which is not what we wanted
to do right we want to transform it back
into what was originally given to us so
having just a single special character
delimiter is not going to work because
that delimiter could actually show up in
some of the words wouldn't it be nice if
in the encoded string we somehow already
knew how many characters would go in the
first word how many characters would go
in the second word etc etc so then we
could just say okay let's take the first
four characters encode it back into the
first word then take the next five
characters and code it into the second
word so how could we you know do
something like that well one way would
basically be by maintaining some kind of
array right when we're given this uh
inputs a list of strings and we want to
encode it to a single string we can for
every single word basically have an
integer right the first word is four
characters the next word is five
characters etc but then where are we
gonna store this list because you know
this is a valid solution if we're
storing this list somewhere but
basically in the description they don't
want us to store any kind of state
variable this encode and decode needs to
be stateless so when we have this list 4
5 we cannot store it in a separate data
structure is it possible for us to store
it in the string itself how about when
we're encoding this we want to know okay
starting at the beginning here how many
of these characters are going to be in
the first word well why not just put
that number at the beginning right 4 at
the beginning of this encoded string
that works because then we can look at
the beginning transform it into an
integer but one thing is what if the
word itself had some integers in it well
now we need another delimiter right
we're gonna have our integer always at
the beginning there's always going to be
an integer at the beginning the string
is always going to start with an integer
that integer is going to represent what
the length of the following word is
going to be but we're going to have a
delimiter in between the integer and
between the word itself
so basically we're going to read each
character until we reach the delimiter
and once we reach the delimiter we're
going to take all the characters that we
just read which are going to be
transformed into an integer so this 4 is
going to be mapped to four and then
we're going to count the next four
characters after the delimiter which in
this case is going to be pound and that
works because we're only going to read
one delimiter we're always gonna we're
gonna expect a single pound sign no
matter what right so even if the first
character here was a pound it still
works because we're gonna read an
integer four read a single pound sign
and then say okay take the next four
characters even if they include pound
even if they included some integer like
eight or you know six or something right
if they include integer pound it doesn't
matter because this tells us how many
characters are going to be in the first
word and then once we read those four
characters what are we going to expect
to be next well we're going to expect
some word but we want to know how long
that word is going to be so we're going
to do exactly what we just did over here
having an integer followed by a pound
sign and we're going to put that same
thing over here so in this case we're
going to have a 5 and a pound sign
because the next word is going to be
five characters long so this is kind of
how we're storing the integers inside of
the encoded string so that we know how
to decode it we know how long each of
the strings is going to be so i hope
this makes sense now i'm going to show
you how to actually code it up by the
way the overall time complexity of
encode and decode is going to be of n
where n is going to be the total number
of characters given to us in the list of
words so with that being said we are
ready to get into the code okay so now
let's get into the code you can see the
interface is a little bit different yes
we are doing this on lint code rather
than leak code because it's free on
there so let's start with the encode
function it's a little bit easier so
remember we're given a list of strings
and we want to encode it into a single
string how are we going to do that well
we're going to go string by string in
the input and to the result we want to
append this encoded string s how are we
encoding it again well remember we're
going to take the length of the string
and you know this the length of the
string is going to be an integer but we
want to transform that into a string so
let's do that in python pretty easily
just like this
plus
we want to add the delimiter to the
pound sign so we have the length of the
string followed by the delimiter pound
sign followed by the string itself s so
then you know this is kind of the format
that we agreed upon this is how we're
going to be encoding it because it's
going to be easy for us to decode this
as well so we're going to do this for
every single string in the input add it
to the result and then we can go ahead
and return that result so encode was
pretty straightforward d decode is going
to be a little bit more tricky but we
know the rules that we can follow so
this time we're given a single string a
single encoded string which is going to
be you know encoded using the function
that we just wrote so how are we going
to decode it into a list of strings in
this case our result is going to be a
list of strings and i'm also going to
have a pointer i which is going to tell
us what position that we're at in the
input string so far so i'm going to just
iterate character by character so while
i is still in bounds we are going to
read character by character basically
decoding each string so when we start
off the first position that we're going
to be at is going to be an integer right
so what we want to do is we want to find
the delimiter we want to find the end of
the integer so we're going to have a
second pointer j initially it's going to
be at i and while the characters the
character at
pointer j is not equal to the pound
meaning that we're still at an integer
character we're going to keep
incrementing j by 1. and we're
guaranteed to find a pound character
right because we that's kind of how we
encoded it up above so we're going to
keep incrementing until we get to that
pound character and then once we get to
the pound character we know that our
integer the length of the following
string is going to be from our string
starting at index i going all the way up
until index j but not including index j
right so that's this portion is going to
be the integer right now it's a string
so we want to uh transform it into or
convert it into an integer we can do
that in python pretty easily just like
this so now this length variable tells
us how many following characters we have
to read after j in order to get every
character of the string so in other
words if we start string at index j plus
1 because remember j is at the delimiter
character so j plus one is going to be
the first character in the string itself
and we want to go all the way until the
end of that string how do we get that
well right now we have the length of
that string so we can say j
plus 1 plus length this will give us the
entire string and what do we want to do
with the string well we want to append
it to the result so let's go ahead and
do just that so basically each iteration
of this loop is gonna read one entire
word and then we're gonna go again loop
again and read more words until we reach
the end of the string but one thing we
forgot is how are we gonna update our
pointer i well we just read a single
word so now we want to start at the next
word how do we get that well our pointer
i is just going to be set to j
plus 1 plus length because this is
actually not this is going to be
basically the beginning of the next
string or it could be the end of the
entire string right but either way this
is how we are going to be updating our j
each iteration of the loop once we're
done with that our result will be
containing all the decoded strings so we
can go ahead and return that result
and as you can see i just ran the code
and it looks like it works and it is
pretty efficient so i hope that this was
helpful let me hide that so i hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it supports the channel a
lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching